Speaker 1: OK, I have video of death cult.
Republican Governor Ron DeSantis. He defiantly and
courageously has announced, no matter what Joe
Biden says about vaccine requirements and what
employers should do in Florida, if you as
an employer require vaccination, you will be
fined five thousand dollars. This guy is going
backwards on just about everything. The crowd
cheering. We have clips, we have conspiracy's.
We have everything. Let's get right into it.
This is Rhonda Santurce yesterday saying vaccine
requirement fines, not vaccine requirements,
fines for vaccine requirements. Here we go.
Speaker 2: And so if a government agency
in the state of Florida forces a
vaccine as a condition to employment,
that violates Florida law. And you will face.
Speaker 1: Now, you know, sycophantic cheering
aside, this is really muddled
because the Biden requirement
is for employers over 100 employees. The Santurce
is talking about state government agencies
requiring it to work. Now, the Biden version has
an opt out, which just requires a weekly test. So
it's not even really clear that this is a
direct response to the Biden requirements.
It's just the DeSantis mess.
Speaker 2:
And you will face a five thousand
dollar fine for every single violation.
Speaker 1: OK, so this is, you know, the party
that says never regulate business. Business
should be allowed. They are now starting to say,
no, let's actually regulate business in this case,
talking about state government agencies
rather than businesses. But he's been pulling
a lot of the very same stuff, then
going on to talk about booster shots,
so-called booster shots, some calling
them third doses. And again, just
so hyperbolic, so sycophantic.
Speaker 2: Here we go.
Can you imagine if Trump had unilaterally set a
date for FDA without there having underlying data?
I mean, the corporate press would have a meltdown.
I mean, it would be wall to wall hysteria.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, Joe Biden talking about
September 20th is the date at which people will
be able to go and get third doses, be able
to go. And the idea that there's anything
tyrannical about that is just as silly as the
idea that there's anything theoretical about any
of the things that have been done so far,
Speaker 2: him perverting science and not
following experts or whatever. And look, I
have no knowledge because I've not seen any
data about these booster shots, but it could
be in a situation where six months from now,
if Foushee says get one, you just have to do
it. Are they going to fire you then at that
point? Are they going to fire you a year from now?
Speaker 1: OK, Deronda Santurce then continuing
on and then giving us some scenario
about forcing an 80 year old to be
vaccinated, pinning down an 80 year old.
Speaker 2: You know, there were some that
just did not want to take it. They did not think
that it was something that was right for them.
And so what are you going to do? You're going to
pin down some 80 year old nursing home resident
and force them to take it? They had for whatever
reason, I don't know what the reasons were,
whether a doctor recommended whether they
had had covered before or what have you.
And so it just shows that. And I also think
that what they're doing is very harmful.
Speaker 1: Yeah, this guy is completely out of
his mind. I mean, it is a death cult of sorts.
I don't even know, quite frankly,
that DeSantis believes this stuff.
I think he knows he's playing to a cult in Florida
and he'll be punished if he doesn't do this stuff.
Here's a clip. I actually can't tell if this was
the same event or not. Let's see. He's wearing the
same suit, although it might be. No, I guess it's
the same room. The lighting is different here. And
a.. Baxter was invited to speak, stood behind the
seal of Florida and said the vaccine changes your
RNA. It doesn't. And DeSantis just stands there.
Speaker 2: The vaccine changes your RNA. So
for me, that's a problem. So I'm here with you
folks. We don't want to have the vaccine. It's
it's about our freedom and liberty.
It's not about the vaccine. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, OK, dissent is looked a
little bit uncomfortable with that. But when he
spoke, he just thanked the guy and did not mention
anything about the fact that the vaccine does not
change your RNA, does not change your RNA. I
don't even think the guy speaking knows what
that means. So a complete death cult continuing
to control Florida, unfortunately. Let's make sure
that a similar death cult doesn't take control of
California by voting no on that recall tonight.